sorry wenn ich im moment wo videos
machen die sich mit leben bzw
außerirdisches leben beschäftigen aber
im moment da poppen die themen nur so
auf unsere wissenschaftler bestätigt wie
einfach die grundbausteine des lebens
entstehen können die rna bin
wahrscheinlich der vorläufer der dna des
erbgutes von leben auf der erde wie
einfach also leben entstehen kann das
jetzt entwicklungszeit weg zum herzlich
willkommen wenn das so stimmt dann
spricht alles dafür dass die bedingungen
für leben sehr einfach sind und im
prinzip dazu auf jedem wasserhaltigen
planeten existieren
der schritt den die evolution machen
muss ist moleküle entstehen zu lassen
die sich selbst replizieren können die
dna ist also quasi ein kleiner bot der
sie selbst vervielfältigen kann dass die
eine einmalige eigenschaft und zudem
noch den bauplan von riesigen organismen
in sich trägt das ist die zweite
sensationelle eigenschaft bereich dem
vom simplen einzeller bis zu uns den
menschen mit vollkommen wahnsinnige
eigenschaften eigentlich intelligenz
kommunikation nutzung von werkzeugen
bewusstsein und viele mehr
die dna ist mit diesen beiden
eigenschaften einen wirklich in der
außergewöhnlichen naturphänomen nicht
von ungefähr glauben viele menschen
deshalb an den feminismus dass sie sich
nicht vorstellen können dass die natur
so etwas kompliziertes ohne einen gott
erschaffen kann aber wer einfach mal
beobachtet und wie schnell sich
lebewesen neuen bedingungen anpassen
können und unsere erde ist milliarden
jahre alt es gab also genug versuche und
fehlversuche um den richtigen weg zu
finden immer besser entwickelte
lebewesen entstehen zu lassen ob wir
eher ein fehlversuch sind naja das ist
ja noch nicht erlebt jetzt haben also
forscher erforscht wie schwierig es ist
die für die rna benötigten
ausgangsstoffe entstehen zu lassen uns
das gegen verblüffend einfach ein team
um das mitglied der tschechischen
akademie der wissenschaften martinsee
roth nahm dazu die aus dem ursuppe
experiment von stanley miller von vor 60
jahren bekannte mixtur das ammoniak
kohlenmonoxid und wasserdampf als die ur
atmosphäre die wir über eine oberfläche
aus ton und wasser einer elektrischen
ladung aussetzen oder auch noch
zusätzlich mit einem laserpuls 1
den einschlag simulierten und das
ergebnis war wirklich sensationell
am ende der chemischen reaktionen die
durch die energie pulse ausgelöst wurden
hatten sie alles was man fürs leben
braucht beziehungsweise erstmal alles
für die rna zitat wird detektiert mit
alle kanonischen rn anouk leoparden
bild zo sin adenin und guanin
zusammengetan stoff unter einfachsten
aminosäure glycin berichten die forscher
weisen wirklich frappierend das
universum bietet demnach die besten
bedingungen um überall leben entstehen
zu lassen und die theorie über aplomb
ihnen als spermien der die wird immer
wahrscheinlicher wie bringen alles was
man braucht auf die gesteinsplaneten
wenn sie mal erkaltet sind die
grundbausteine des lebens und auch die
perfekten bedingungen durch ihre
einschläge werden die ersten chemischen
reaktionen angestoßen auf denen dann die
grundbausteine des lebens entstehen und
in ihren körpern bilden sich ideale
lebensbedingungen
damit sich die moleküle weiter
entwickeln und sie schließlich die dna
und die ersten lebewesen bilden können
wahnsinn ich bin mal gespannt was die
nasa heute zum möglichen leben auf
enceladus sagt der link zum livestream
zur pressekonferenz ist und in der video
beschreibung ich machen sobald ich alle
infos haben natürlich im video dazu und
wenn es nicht verpassen wollt dann
solltet ihr hier ein abo aufsaugen gibt
noch gerne einen auf die glocke um die
besten videos die diejenigen bisher
verpasst haben die noch nicht abonniert
haben die findet ihr hier in der best
auf playlist da mal durch es gibt noch
so viele spannende themen also bis dann